hey friends so saturday was world mental
health day
and as somebody who struggles with
mental health i wanted to take this as
an
opportunity to talk a little bit about
my own struggles with mental health
and hopefully help some of y'all out
there
that are likewise struggling to feel a
little less alone drex here from
drexfactorpoi bringing you the love of
poi spinning and flow arts to benefit
your body and brain and
today we're going to be talking a lot
about brain stuff and
specifically mental health mental
illness and um
i will warn you up front there is a
content slash trigger warning for this
we're going to be talking about
some kind of difficult subjects in this
video including depression
and suicidal ideation and anxiety before
we dive in i just want to give a quick
shout out to the friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk
flow fests flow toys pyroterra light
toys
lmf props spinballs and ultra poi for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible
you can learn more about all these
amazing companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
that i've got down in the description
of this video so this is not the video
that i thought i was
posting today um originally the plan was
to post the second half of that video
series on the art that inspired me and
that is going to be uh coming out on
wednesday now but um
this was kind of an unexpected moment
for me not only because
um i think in the past couple years i've
been
doing a lot more work to kind of
acknowledge and work through my own
mental health issues but also
um because in the past couple weeks i
have
started to feel the familiar pull of
seasonal depression hitting me
i i wanted to talk about this experience
openly
partially to educate people out there
that don't suffer from these mental
health problems and also too
because you know it's taken me a long
time to
come around to the point where i can
look at myself
and realize that um you know i do
suffer from mental illnesses and you
know both that that's okay
that there's nothing wrong with that and
also
to be kind to myself to not think of
those things
as being things that like hobble me or
keep me from being able to engage with
life or anything like that
i first started showing symptoms of
depression when i was quite young
at least as early as like four or five
um and it was very very clear that it
was
a major mental health problem for me by
the time i was
uh seven or eight um we know this
because
that's when i made my first suicide
attempt
that was not my last suicide attempt but
it was a pretty big wake-up call both
for me as well as
for the people around me i was put into
therapy twice as a child
once right after that first suicide
attempt and then again
in my early teen years um
looking back on it it's very difficult
to say whether
either of those rounds of therapy was at
all helpful for me because at the time i
didn't know how to talk about
my mental illness and that made it
really difficult for
therapists to be able to kind of
help me in identifying behavioral
problems and everything and how to cope
with those
okay so what does that depression look
like for me um
i just recently had a conversation about
this with my therapist where we kind of
identified what my depression is on
basically like a ten point scale
so um from about a one
two a four i
have problems with what i call inertia
that is
um it is difficult for me to get moving
on tasks
you know i'll it'll take me a couple
hours to get to
even get out of bed sometimes and it's
not like i'm
sitting there just like full of
self-loathing or what have you it's just
like the mental energy to physically get
up
is really difficult and it really sucks
because even when i do get stuff done
like you know that little like dopamine
kick that you get
whenever you complete a task or you're
proud of something you've done or what
have you
it doesn't exist it just disappears so
even if i get something done i don't get
any satisfaction from it
so when i get to about a five to a seven
on
my scale uh this is one is the least and
ten is the greatest
uh symptoms from this um this is when i
start
losing social functioning you know how
they're kind of like unspoken
rules to social interactions like how
you have play conversation and how you
respond
to people something happens to me in
this state
where it's like i can't find the rule
book anymore like i
don't know how like i physically just
don't know how to hold down
conversations
um and it really sucks because i feel
super guilty
about like not being able to interact
with people like a normal human being
and i
start like isolating myself from other
people because i feel kind of ashamed of
it and everything you know
this can have a snowballing effect and
cause
greater problems with depression because
of course as you isolate yourself in a
lot of cases you're also kind of like
cutting off uh your base of support and
everything and the final stage of it for
me
is what i would put unlike a seven to
ten on the scale
um which is thoughts of self-harm
and or suicidal ideation in a lot of
cases
this is the stage of it where it's not
just
difficulties getting moving or
difficulties like remembering how to
human
it is like a feeling of self-loathing it
is
a feeling of like you know
imagining that people would be better
off without me or that i'm a burden on
them
or that like you know it it becomes one
of those things
where you feel invisible to a point
where you're just like okay
then i guess i just disappear then right
okay so now that we have talked in a
very clinical fashion
about um a very scary problem
how do i treat my depression how do i
deal with it um i have several different
ways
one of the more recent ones which is
like in the past decade or so
is when i start feeling um the symptoms
of depression coming on
even like stuff that's in the early part
of the scale the one to four and
everything where i'm just like having a
tough time getting moving and everything
i'll usually start taking st john's wort
i know that the research on that is is
kind of mixed in terms of its efficacy
but it's kind of a low tier
solution for me that if nothing else um
like
will take the edge off the lows and in
before
anybody asks this question no i have
never taken medication for depression
i'm afraid to try it honestly
i i'm i'm afraid to try it and have it
go horribly wrong
that said i do not want that
to be something that people hear and
think that medication is not an
option medication saves lives
for those of you out there that are on
medication um
no there is no judgment there whatsoever
and i hope
that it is the help that uh you needed
in order to manage
uh your own mental health problems i
also try to exercise regularly i run
several times a week and of course flow
arts is a part of that
it is now an active part of my routine
that
like one of the ways that i finish up
work for the day is
i will go out and go spin some poi
and like flow out you know i will use
some of that
time to specifically like dance and flow
and work out whatever's going on in my
head and like identify
whatever i'm feeling and whatever i kind
of
need to process and work through and
everything and finally
i have been regularly seeing a therapist
now for almost two years
having my therapist has been an
invaluable
resource because talking
with them is a sandbox where
i get to express all of the things that
i'm kind of afraid to talk about with
other people
and to be able to talk openly about
things that you know i'm kind of afraid
of receiving judgment on such as mental
health one of these places where there's
still
a lot of work to be done though is in
asking for help from the people around
me
my natural inclination is to isolate
myself
one of those things that i have to deal
with and that i have to figure out for
myself in the long run
is identifying the ways in which i can
ask other people for help
and depend on them and everything
goodness so
after all of that why exactly am i
making this video
um the biggest reason is
that i hope that other people that are
out there that are hearing me talk about
these things
and hearing
the struggles that i'm dealing with will
hear something that resonates with them
and know that they're not alone this
isn't something that you need to be
ashamed of it's not
something that has made you broken or
that makes you weak
i want to present to people out there
that don't suffer from these mental
health problems that
guess what this this right here this is
actually
what depression can look like um and
unless i told you i don't think a single
person out there watching this video
would suspect
that i was experiencing the symptoms of
depression right now or had been for
a couple weeks now i still wrestle with
like feeling ashamed talking about it
and everything i feel like i'm calling
too much attention to myself
i feel like people are going to start
grading me on a curve
i feel like you know people are going to
pity me
or try to like you know one one thing
just in talking about depression the
past couple weeks it's been very clear
talking from a lot of people and saying
yeah i'm i'm experiencing depression
that they're not sure of like oh does
that mean he's about to kill himself
it's like
no it there there are gradations here
if you know somebody who's struggling
and has come to you and talked about it
and everything
ask them what their experiences are ask
them
what they're experiencing right then
rather than assuming that you know what
that looks like
because you know my symptoms are going
to have some overlap with other people
and also too other people are going to
have different experiences than i've had
and finally for those of you out there
that are struggling i want to encourage
you to go
out and get the help that you need and
yes
i know how incredibly difficult that can
be i navigated
trying to find a therapist at a point in
my life
where i was suicidal and it is one of
the most difficult things i've ever done
when you're struggling to muster the
will
to even keep on living and everything
having to go through the process of
auditioning different therapists
and figuring out which one is right for
you is tough
but the effort is worth it i swear to
you it's worth it
and if you are like me and don't have
all of the financial resources
um i would recommend the service that i
use to find my own therapist is called
open path collective i will leave a link
down in the description
um basically it is a
directory of therapists that offer up
their services at a steep discount
for people that are financially strapped
goodness
so that was a lot and a lot of very
personal stuff
um and the anxiety welling up in me is
hoping that people don't think less of
me or judge me for
having made this video and for having
talked to all of you about this
but um this is one of those stages in
the mental health journey
it is uh learning how to
talk about what i wrestle with and what
a lot of people wrestle with
and also to accept this part of myself
and that it is a part of me and that's
okay
and if this is a part of youtube then
it's also okay and uh you know what
um i'm really proud of you for for being
here and
for working through it and
um yeah if you need help i hope that you
get the help that you need yeah
and if you're watching this and you know
somebody that struggles
check in on them let them know that you
care
don't wait for them to come to you
because
when they're in bad enough position that
that's necessary is going to be the
hardest time for them to do it
yeah awesome thank you all so much for
watching
um please make sure to like share
comment and subscribe
to help other people find this video and
hopefully benefit from it
and a huge thank you because this video
would not be possible without the kind
contributions
of these wonderful folks right here they
are my flow patrons on patreon and they
along with the wonderful people
listed down in the description uh make
this video and all the videos on this
channel possible
a video like this one would not exist
without their support
because you know the youtube algorithm
is such that
it encourages you to find your niche and
stay in it and never deviate even a
little bit from it
so somebody who runs a flow arts channel
talking
about mental health and the impact that
it has had on them and everything
um the incentives on this platform are
not geared in that direction
so thank you all um if you would like to
sign up to support the work that i do
and help me in this mission to teach
flow arts and really support people all
over the world
that i hope can benefit from
getting up and using their bodies in a
new and creative way
you can sign up to support that work
head on over to
patreon.com drexfactorpoi
there you can get early access to all of
my content as well as a say in what
topics i tackle in the future
uh and plus some nice behind-the-scenes
stuff and extras get posted every once
in a while
so yeah go check that out please and
thank you cool so
um thank you all out there for humoring
me and for listening and
um yeah once again those of you out
there that
are struggling on a world mental health
day and everything um i'm proud of you
and i i feel you
we're in this together you're not alone
i swear you're not alone
no matter how much you feel like it um
so yeah be kind to each other take care
of each other
and take care of yourselves too please
and thank you